I would like to express firstly my admiration for a great man, Nelson Mandela.
You're an example to us all of perseverance, forgiveness, strength, wisdom and grace.
Never before in history was one human being so universally acknowledged in his lifetime...
...as the embodiment of magnanimity and reconciliation as Nelson Mandela.
We have all equally been awed by his dedication to others...
...and by his inspiration to serve as he did.
We're here to build a more just and peaceful world.
Please, please, please, on the 18th of July let's stand together.
Give 67 minutes of your time to do what you can.
I would like to encourage everyone to do something worthy for someone else on Mandela Day.
I will also be giving my 67 minutes...
...to make the world a better place one small step at a time.
I ask you to celebrate by following his example...
...by doing your best to help others with a full, happy, grateful heart.
Take action.
Inspire change.
Make every day Mandela Day.
We're made for one another.
Together, we can create a better world.
Thank you for your example, Madiba.